you know eventually there's going to be  a recession right unless something  changes eventually there's a recession  there's one coming at some point but  there are people who have been  predicting massive recessions imminently  since 2012 many since 2016 and some more  recently is it really a good prediction  if you predict the same thing for a  decade and eventually it happens it's  sort of like if I prod if I could live  for a few billion years and I keep  predicting that at some point the Sun is  going to swell and engulf the Earth  at some point the prediction will become  prescient And Timely but predicting it  every single day and telling people  you'd better watch out because it could  be tomorrow it doesn't really make it  for a good prediction